[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans les
studios du figaro on est en direct c'est
figaro live et on attend vos points de
vue notamment après l annonce par les
labos rect laboratoire américain pfizer
de l'arrivée imminente d'un vaccin
faut-il comme le souhaite
yannick jadot rendre le vaccin
obligatoire contre lakovic 19 c'est la
question qu'on pose sur le site du
figaro depuis la mi journée
bonsoir alexis brézet bon sens enfin
vous êtes le directeur des rédactions du
figaro et on revient largement dans la
prochaine édition papier sur sur ce
débat sur le débat des questions autour
du vaccin est toute la question qu'on
peut se poser en essayant de répondre
essayant on va alors peut-être pas y
répondre en tout cas en débattre aussi
avec les béatrice giblin ce soir en soir
béatrice massin et on rappelle que vous
êtes rédactrice en chef de la revue
hérodote est en une de la dernière
livraison la géopolitique de l'afrique
médiane alors comme ça le titre est un
peu mystérieux et à la lecture c'est
absolument passionnant comprend pourquoi
les pays qui ont des grandes forêts ont
un état qui n'est pas toujours très fort
et on découvre les étonnantes ambitions
de la norvège dans cette partie du monde
c'est à découvrir donc dans la dernière
livraison de la revue hérodote
on rappelle enfin béatrice que vous êtes
professeur approuvez-vous la
mobilisation et la grève de certains
enseignants aujourd'hui c'est la
question qu'on vous posera et c'est la
question qu'on vous pose également sur
twitter c'est l'autre débat de ce soir
mais d'abord ce débat qui risque
d'agiter à tout le moins europe ecologie
les verts un pays un parti qui est très
divisé sur la question des vaccins sans
doute encore plus après ses propos ce
matin de yannick jadot chez nos
confrères de france info
j'espère que tout le monde va participer
à la fois aujourd'hui je le rappel du
respect des règles très strict
le vaccin n'est pas là faut pas relâcher
les efforts et puis quand le vaccin sera
là dessus a vacciné il faut qu'il soit
obligatoire
oui oui oui on vaccine obligatoirement
les français mais oui 40 ou 50% de
réticents aujourd'hui on leur dit même
si je dois obligatoirement ben là je
crois qu'il faut il faut attendre
pardon je m'attendais pas à cette
réponse non parce que tu as regardé le
traumatisme que vivent nos sociétés
alors on s'entendrait pas cette réponse
chez les écologistes on sait que par
exemple élus michèle rivasi est opposé à
toute forme de deux vaccins alexis jadot
dans cette séquence là il dit ce qu'il
pense
où il s'est laissé un peu embarqué par
la question déjà on est comme un pays
extraordinaire nous annonce qu'avec ça
on n'est même pas sûr que ce vaccin
fonctionne on sait pas qui va
s'appliquer qu'en quand on voit le
distribuer ci sera efficace pour les
personnes à risque si l'immunité sera
définitive ou temporaire
enfin on ne sait absolument rien on est
déjà en train commencé à s'engueuler ce
que nous allons peut-être ferons
peut-être pour être d'accord je n'en
sais rien on va discuter à lancer un
débat sur le point de savoir et ça c'est
comme le génie français sur renault ce
truc dont on n'est même pas sûr que ça
va exister c'est déjà en bonne rendre
obligatoire c'est quand même moi je veux
dire c'est invraisemblable dans la façon
d'aborder un sujet seul acte cela étant
dit je ne sais pas si je ne vois pas ce
que jadot a dans la tête je ne sais pas
c'est vrai que de la part d'un écolo
libertaire qu'on suppose proche des
choses de médecine naturelle ont plaisir
à il est peut-être anti-vaccins
maintenant apparemment il n'est pas tant
mieux cela dit moi alors si vous me
demandez mon avis
et je passe tout de suite la parole
après vite et je pense que c'est une ce
serait une bêtise mais je serai prêt le
développer de rendre ce vaccin
obligatoire
alors justement béatrice peut-être un
commentaire sur ce que veut dire alexis
est ce qu'on est un pays formidable de
s'engueuler déjà sur des choses qui
n'ont pas été encore j'allais dire la
même chose on sait même pas encore quand
est-ce qu'il va venir on sait aucune
vraiment de cette caractéristique on
sait pas ça durait l'immunité
bref on sent un bonbon comme de la part
de pfizer sas est incontestable et
doivent pas être trop loin quand même le
faire ce genre de communication avec
rien qui suit derrière ça c'est
éminemment dangereux aussi
donc s'il se lance comme ça en demandant
sans doute une autorisation distille
dans deux ou trois semaines
est ce qu'il y aura l'autorisation des
états unis bon je pense que c'est
peut-être dans l'ordre des choses
possibles s'est pas laissée passer par
une boîte de cette taille là c'est le
regard des autorités boursières
médicales américaines qui sont quand
même pas commode qui commence à raconter
des blagues ça leur coûtera cher très
très très très très cher etc des boîtes
qui sort pour gagner de l'argent donc
les choses qui leur coûte cher de ma
peau
donc nous pouvons avoir trois minutes de
gloire à quoi ça servirait jeu gagnera
autre milliard et demi de dollars
et puis regardez ils ont quand même
attendu que les élections soient passés
qu'abidal soit bien confirmer parce que
il aurait peut-être pu faire ça il ya 8
10 jours un autre homme leur rôle mais
tramelan reprises le peu de chance je
pense que c'est pas tout à fait par
hasard ce qui est seulement dit
maintenant donc ici se lance comment
vous l'avez interpréter justement parce
que s'il était est-ce que pas aussi les
fiables aujourd'hui à 90% et peut-être
que la semaine dernière au s'ils étaient
fiables 90 c'est possible on peut lutter
lundi dernier la veille
eh ben il n'avait pas envie de donner un
coup de pouce à trump voilà et peut-être
pas envie d'être pris dans une rigole et
mis exactement on les aurait accusé
d'être instrumentalisé par travail
qu'est ce qu'on aurait dit ah bah
évidemment d'accord trois jours avant
l'élection il a trouvé un labo qui
grille raconte qu'un valable 1
un vaccin il y aurait juste 50% des gens
qui sont anti tram qu'il n'y aurait pas
cru et 50% des protons c'est la preuve
peut-être que ça aurait changé quelque
chose
résultat ça on n'en sait rien mais pour
la boîte pour pfizer
c'était la seule chose qui fait que ça
n'est pas une bonne affaire
cela l'a d'ailleurs personne ne met en
doute dans la réalité de leur annonce
qu'ils sont quand même associé aux
allemands ils sont pas tout seul donc
peut-être aussi que les allemands
quelque chose à dire là pied la france
donc le disais on dit tout ça justement
sur la sueur sur le vaccin et le pays
les plus le plus réticent sur les
réactions si cela y compris sur celui-là
55% d'efforts au pays de pasteur un
raymond pays de pasteur
on est vous avez anticipé ma question
est ce que vous comprenez ces français
qui refusent le vaccin vous les
condamnez jeu je ne les comprends pas
j'ai pas à condamner les français mais
je ne les comprends pas c'est absolument
irrationnel vous avez cités madame
rivasi
c'est quand même une scientifique c'est
quand même quelqu'un qui a à uva et bien
les plus grands diplômes puisqu'elle
fait normale supérieure bon c'est quand
même pas rien et qu'ils puissent être
anti vaccins pour moi c'est une
incompréhension totale parce que
scientifiquement je dire il ya personne
ne peut contester l'utilité du vaccin et
je pense que la précédente ministre de
la santé agnès buzyn a bien fait
d'imposer un certain nombre de vaccins
aux enfants fait on a encore des enfants
qui n'ont d'autres pays peuvent mourir
de la rougeole
bon c'est quand même invraisemblable
vous croyez pas toutes de grâce aux
effets secondaires non absolument pas
les effets secondaires je dis pas qu'il
y en ait pas mais par rapport à la
gravité
effectivement quand on n'est pas
vaccinée j'ai l'iran va se réjouir que
la polio soit des noms soient
débarrassés quand même moi dans mon
enfance et eu des copines qui ont eu la
polio bon ben j'ai vu ce que ça a donné
non c'est ccc c'est pas sérieux quoi
franchement c'est pas sérieux
une des questions mais autres dont je
n'ai pas la réponse c'est pourquoi en
france le
le phénomène des vaccins est si fort si
prévenant si profond c'est curieux je ne
crois pas ça mériterait je ne crois pas
que dans les autres pays occidentaux
beaucoup ça donc d'où ça vient j'ai dit
l'affrontement historique culturel
psychologique d'oussalah il y à une
géographie des anti vaccins elles ne
seraient partis pas du tout de façon
identique homogène sur l'ensemble du
territoire
c'est déjà une donnée qui est importante
on peut s'en rendre compte avec la
diffusion par exemple j'ai dirigé une
thèse sur l'épidémie de rougeole
maintenant une petite dizaine d'années
qu'elle avait eu lieu et on voyait bien
ces partis de deux endroits qui ont
étonné tout le monde
l'un bourgogne l'autre du côté d'arras
quand deux écoles religieuses une de
filles une de garçons alors les enquêtes
ont été ses ils ont montré que c'était
des écoles religieuses saint-pie dijon
sais pas quoi enfin extrêmement très
conservatrice on va dire et très
opposées au vaccin très très opposées au
vaccin et c'était la même famille les
filles étaient dans ce projet national
et garçons de l'autre et du coup la
diffusion s'est fait tomber ce qui est
intéressant c'est de se rendre compte
parce que la rougeole est aussi
contagieuse que je crois que l'aco vide
commence à se diffuser après geosam en
sus va commander sinon ça sue est ce que
ça ne sais plus et 30% de d'intégristes
catholiques ans non mais ça ne s'est pas
diffuser dans tous les milieux de la
même manière par exemple et vous avez
cité jaloux j'attendais pas mauvaise
mais pas du tout il fait partie de cet
endroit qui descend le long de l'art du
rhône avec une drôme avec une ardeur et
qui est sur un milieu on va dire très
marquée encore après 68 un peu
libertaire donc on refuse tout ce qui
est loi impose des contraintes déjà très
vous de l'abbé très justement dit alexis
naturopathe médecines parallèles et
autres et qui sont dans un micro milieu
dans lequel vous avez d'ailleurs
énormément d'infirmières sages-femmes
les gens dont on ne s'attend pas à ce
qu'ils soient y compris et on a même
trouvé en ardèche dans un des cantons de
l'ardèche
un médecin de pmi qui était anti vaccins
c'est invraisemblable
pareil pour vous allécher a trouvé ça au
nord de la france jamais trouvé ça en
bretagne un peu en alsace est-ce que
vous avez des écoles particulière ces
modèles montessori mais c'est une autre
à la fois l'héritage de mai 68 en partie
un héritage des d'écoles de liberté se
cherche le nom c'est ça le cher le lait
l'école c'est une école alsacienne avec
d'autres modèles ou là en alsace est
assez fort ça peut être aussi des
composantes
on va dire oui les libertaires il ya une
même en ardèche par exemple pourrait
faire la différence entre comment on se
comporte en oeuvre des gens du sud
mais comment on se comporte en ardèche
du nord eh ben c'est pas la même chose
et ça ça date de siegfried un nom mais
ça c'est extrêmement intéressant
leur salut que les internautes de toutes
ces régions là
je
il ya une vérification en cours par le
figaro sur la possibilité juridique de
contraindre à la vaccination
a priori c'est possible compliqué parce
qu'on peut pour les enfants c'est la
scolarisation qui est levé 11
c'est à dire qu'on ne peut pas juste il
n'y a pas de certificat
bravo lui demander si nation dans la rue
un enfant on peut pas aller avec de
bonnes récoltes encore lisse et voilà un
damné je suis pas du tout sûr que
juridiquement je viens possible je
posais cette question c'est vrai mais
enfin bon ça devient compliqué d'après
mme constitutionnel c'est compliqué un
peu on peut penser quand même qu'alex
qu'on vient de vivre
on est quand même une charte un nombre
de français qui ait envie de se vacciner
dans une très grande majorité
bon à partir du moment où on dit si on
avait 60 % de taux d'immunité baye
aurait pu vraiment problème et satya que
leur est plus on n'a aucune raison
d'imposer à tout le monde de se vacciner
parce que je pense qu'il aura bien 60 %
d'adultes largement qu'ils vont se
vacciner pour se débarrasser mais
bleville bon c'est pourtant il donc la
pression et ça c'est grave
d'autant que le 60 % c'est pour un taux
de circulation de 2,2 entre 2 et 3 si le
taux de celle ci le r le fameux air est
ce qu'il est aujourd'hui
un peu plus au dessus de la semap yama
pas besoin de 60 % avec 30% de vacciner
ça suffit si une personne sur trois est
fait cuisiner quand chaque fois qu'on
rencontre une personne on en comptait 10
022 plus bas il s'arrête ça s'arrêtera
donc c'est pas la peine d'aller chercher
la vérité c'est sûr que si on le rend
obligatoire
alors là on aura le grand complot les
laboratoires qui s'en mettent plein les
poches
la volonté de contrôler on va mettre des
puces électroniques dans le sens et je
ne sais de quoi je ne sais quoi c'est
pas la peine
il y aura bien suffisamment de gens qui
seront volontaires le vrai sujet n'est
pas de consolation
2 est ce qu'on aura à c e
donc après tout c'est parce que ça est
ce qu'on aura suffisamment de doses tout
de suite est ce qu'on pourra en produire
assez toxique des gens ne souhaitent pas
quand il ya besoin que tout le monde
serait content signer et de ce point de
vue le calcul que je ne défend pas et je
suis pas du tout dans les anti vaccins
mais de ne pas se vacciner peut être un
calcul rationnel en se disant les autres
se vaccine pour moi k
quelqu'un de non vaccinés comme tous les
parents d'enfants
mes enfants sont pas malins n'ont
présenté à son homologue ce que si 70%
des autres sont vaccinés ou 80% 80 95 %
des enfants n'ont aucune chance
d'attraper la rougeole donc le
l'assurance s'est amaigri du collectif
le jeu donnait la parole aux internautes
juste si vous allez vous faire vacciner
d'être il surprenait quel vaccin le
russe l'américain paul chinois ce que
visiblement n'y renonce je pense que ça
serait l'amérique donc négocié a peur
dur non j'irai choisir le plus fiable
c'est à dire je dirais choisir celui que
les autorités sanitaires françaises nous
aurons conseillers jugent seuil il ya
une des remarques et d'internautes
c'est très intéressant parce que c'est
polarisé très polarisée alors jacques
nous dit la loi kouchner indique coq
2002 il me semble indique qu'aucun acte
médical ne peut être pratiqué sans le
consentement libre et éclairé du patient
camille dit je suis d'accord avec vous
la question ne se pose pas encore le
vaccin n'est pas encore là nicole nous
dit rendre obligatoire un vaccin dont on
ne sait rien et surtout pas les effets
secondaires trois petits points donc on
sent que vinicole n'y a pas pas envie
d'aller se faire vacciner me faire
vacciner par avec saint dont les tests
ont été faits en accéléré très peu pour
moi nous dit bertrand voilà
effectivement nicole nous confirme elle
ne veut pas de vaccin obligatoire et
ctci nous dit il est loin le temps de
liberté du consentement libre et éclairé
du patient à l'invers samuel la france
va encore blablater pendant des semaines
alors que des gens sont en train de
mourir du coc vide sur ce vaccin
j'écouterai ce que diront les médecins
nous dit le même le même samuel alors la
question qui est posée sur le site du
figaro faut-il rendre obligatoire la
vaccination contre la coved et bien au
début de cette émission on était à 52 59
2% n'ont hélas on est à plus de 61% donc
de gens qui sont opposés aux caractères
en tous les cas obligatoire du vaccin
comme chris ross que on salue et
babineau nous dit rendre obligatoire le
vaccin serait contre-productif le niveau
de défiance est suffisamment élevé dit
il y à une autre question qu'on vous
pose sur sur twitter c'est
approuvez-vous le mouvement de grève des
enseignants pour réclamer un
renforcement du protocole sanitaire
contre la copie de 10,9 alors on ajoute
que je dire un conseil de défense que
jean castex doit se prononcer dans la
soirée quand on évoque déjà parmi les
hypothèses la fermeture d'écoles et
collèges en tout cas sur le concert
marystelle pêche aujourd'hui la grève
dans l'éducation nationale est peu suivi
8 à 10% selon le ministère la mi journée
un petit peu plus selon les syndicats
ce qui est sûr ce que le sujet vous
passionne d'après ce qu'on voit sur le
trafic dans le sur le site du figaro
aujourd'hui
alors on vous a posé la question sur
l'approbation ou non de la grève des
enseignants il y en a certains qui
l'approuvent ce sont les las les lycéens
qui manifestent notamment devant
certains lycées en particulier lycée
colbert à paris témoignage masqué
anonyme de l'une d'entre elles
nous ce qu'on attend vraiment c'est soit
la fermeture des lycées soit un vrai
protocole sanitaire parce que nous on
fait de la chose qu'il craint le plus
c'est qu'on a des familles on vit avec
des gens parce qu'on est encore mineur
on a nos parents des fois même nos
grands-parents des fois on était famille
nombreuse parce qu'on est quand même à
colbert on est quand même dans un lycée
qui vous un quartier défavorisé on va
dire il ya des familles qui n'ont pas
forcément les moyens et en fait ils sont
dans les tout petits appartements votre
réaction
m je peux vous dire que si j'ai enseigné
encore je n'aurais pas fait greffe
donc ça vous donne des voix pourquoi
parce que écouter j'habite entre deux
grands lycées un lycée général et lycée
technologique et neuf sans doute que
sada nombre d'élèves on fait grève et
quand je les vois tous à la sortie du
lycée
les masques sous le menton se prenant
dans les bras tout à côté les uns des
autres comme comme on a tous et à la
sortie d'un lycée quoi c'est tout alors
après entendre le discours que à la
cantine qu' on n'a pas dit censure
sociale et tout bon franchement
honnêtement ça fait un peu sourire pour
des enseignants la chose est sans doute
différente je ferai de la différence
entre mais c'est pas les enseignants qui
ont bloqué et colbert ou qui ont bloqué
un autre lycée s'est passé à 10 heures
du matin il y avait plus de blocage
comme l'a dit cette jeune fille on veut
ou la fermeture elle a commencé par ça
ouh ouh
du 10 mai un jour sur deux ou je sais
pas quoi bon la fermeture du lycée c'est
toujours un peu sympa quand même bon
voilà mais ce n'est certainement pas la
majorité des élèves non plus moi j'ai
des petits enfants qui apprécient
moyennement cette situation là et dans
le lycée sont déjà maintenant avec un
système d'un jour sur deux ou deux jours
sur trois ans ça s'organise selon les
lycées bon mais pour les enseignants il
peut y avoir eu une inquiétude
on peut aussi leur fournir peut-être des
masques qu'ils soient plus efficaces que
les masques nous avons tous et qu'on
change le plus ou moins dans les bonnes
conditions d'ailleurs bon mais ça peut
se comprendre mais je me doute aussi que
sans doute à la salle des profs
bah ça doit être un pas autant qu'à la
sortie du lycée mais ça doit quand même
bien est un peu comme ça donc je trouve
que là on peut pas tenir le discours
c'est essentiel pour les enfants il faut
qu'ils aient des cols il faut qu'il soit
présent ce qui est vrai moi je la tue je
suis d'accord je vois même les ravages à
l'université de ce qui passe en distance
yale donc je crois que maintenir du
présentiel et est indispensable que au
moment du pic et là où c'est plus grave
on essaye effectivement de ménager la
chèvre et le chou comme on peut pendant
un temps limité
oui peut-être mais pour le reste non je
ne souscris pas toutes façons il ya
longtemps que je ne crois plus à la
grève des enseignants donc pas plus
maintenant qu autrefois vous demandera
peut-être pourquoi mais par contre il ya
cet internaute alexis qui dit qui est
pas d'accord avec vous béatrice qui dit
on nous fait tout un sketch la
dangerosité du virus nous disent itx
mais on envoie les gamins à 30 par
classe ces jeux
aujourd'hui je suis tout à fait d'accord
avec batterie sera à peu près tous les
sujets donc je le redis n'a encore un la
vie se fiche de nous c'est d'abord c'est
souvent cdc en fait c'est des syndicats
miliciens et l'ultra politisés qui font
de l'agit-prop et c'est ma femme qui
viennent pas nous raconter qu'ils sont
tétanisés à l'idée d'aller au lycée et
il faut il songer au bistrot enfin bon
cd tout ça c'était les airs mais oui ma
femme ont les mêmes foules
là j'ai quelques enfants et je les sens
pas dévoré par la peur et d'ailleurs je
les comprends et je les sens plutôt
dévorée par l'exaspération d'être
enfermé d'être à distance quand ils sont
à distance de plus pouvoir sortir de
pouvoir voir leurs amis d'avoir une vie
qui est quand même pas agréable et et
c'est vrai que dans un produit on est
con on en train d'imposer à cette
génération des conditions de vie qui
sont sinistres donc ça je les comprends
de râler contre ça mais de dire ouh là
là on a peur d'aller au lycée non ils
n'ont pas envie d'aller au lycée on peut
le comprendre mais c'est pour une autre
raison les profs je reconnais que c'est
un peu plus compliqué parce que c'est
vrai que quand on est prof et qu'on est
face à trente adolescents ou jeunes
c'est vrai qui a risqué le risque il
faut essayer de le limiter par des
masses par des distances etc
oui il ya un risque mais il ya risque au
combien est sûrement plus élevés pour
les pour les personnels soignants et à
risque aussi dans les entreprises pour
les gens dans les entreprises il ya
risque aussi dans les familles dont les
hypermarchés yaris partout donc c'est
vrai je peux comprendre que c'est un
nombre d'enseignants soient inquiets et
nous les élèves se retrouvent entassés
bon mais on essaie d'y répondre le
ministère essaie de répondre en disant
on va faire des 2000 places
on va faire des tests ça c'est important
et c'est un peu l'idée d'avoir
d'utiliser enfin les tests jugés nantis
génique qui donnerait le résultat une
demi heure
et quitte à les faire deux fois par
semaine les enseignants très bien ils
font leur test ça les rassure et ça
permet aussi d'isoler ceux qui se
seraient serait malade et ça serait très
bien
on peut pour être aussi peut-être tester
les élèves après tous les tests anti
voile qu'ils envoient y voilà bon ben
donc on peut faire des choses
après j'ai un peu le sentiment que
derrière ces mouvements de grève et il
ya aussi des revendications qui sont des
revendications syndicales
traditionnelles qu'on connaît par coeur
et quand on regarde le mot d'ordre c'est
le manque de moyens nécessaires dans les
établissements scolaires pour mettre en
oeuvre le protocole sanitaire et les
moyens on nous dit c'est pourquoi nous
vous demandons de procéder dès à présent
des recrutements de personnel donc les
syndicats comme de juste et comme 2
traditionnellement font des mouvements
pour dire il faut recruter plus de profs
du nord bon c'est pas le lieu ici d'en
débattre
mais j'ai l'impression que la sphère
sanitaire est un peu utilisé un prétexte
pour ça mais je reconnais que c'est
quand même un sujet
que donc il faut il faut sûrement
prendre des précautions mais en même
temps on ne peut pas d'abord on me
semble-t-il le sacrifice qui serait de
se dire parce que la conséquence de tout
ça c'est qu'on serons fermes et déjà les
lycées on n'est qu'à un certain entrain
de on est en train de petit à petit de
de réduire la présence
et si demain c'est les collèges et si
après demain c'est les écoles c'est
catastrophique c'est catastrophique pour
les enfants absolument
et là on a des études qui le montrent
qu'ils montrent que le niveau se casse
la figure c'est très très surtout dans
les cas voilà voilà
et c'est catastrophique pour les parents
et pour l'économie
parce que parce qu'ensuite on dit on ne
rend il faut le faire du télétravail
faire du télétravail une phase de
montage mais tout le monde sait que pour
des parents c'est déjà peut être pas
toujours facile de travailler chez soi
dans un appartement qui est pas très
grand mais si on a plus on a un deux
trois enfants qui courent dans les
pattes c'est impossible on peut pas
travailler il faut le faire travailler
en plus et en plus faut les faire
travailler et utiliser l'ordinateur
on n'a pas non plus six ordinateurs donc
si le enfin on peut pas utiliser
l'ordinateur pour faire travailler ses
deux enfants en distance yale plus le
sien pour travailler enfin c'est il ya
un moment c'est trop compliqué donc pour
plein de raisons c'est très important de
laisser les enfants à l'école
après faut essayer de prendre un maximum
de précautions sachant qu'à pas de ya
pas de de sûreté absolue oui c'est vrai
ça change vous citez cette étude qui a
été faite l'évaluation par le ministère
de l'éducation nationale du premier
enseignement sur la base de tests qui
ont été faits sur des élèves donc au
conseil de la rentrée et effectivement
c'est assez alarmant parce qu'on voit
une baisse de niveau en cp en c1
c'est à dire au moment où on apprend à
lire mais elle est très inégale là aussi
il ya des gens tant d une enseignante ce
matin de nice qui disait bannu dans un
quartier de nice aisée nous on n'a rien
on n'a pas vu du tout 2
debès parce qu on a eu des parents
qu'ils sont investis compagnie etc
mais d'autres endroits les parents n'ont
pas forcément le temps pas forcément
tout ce qu'elle dit alexis donc c'est un
facteur supplémentaire d'aggravation des
inégalités
donc il faut il faut vraiment lutter
contre et permettre aux enfants d'aller
à l'école
je vous fais partager les réactions des
internautes du figaro dont babineau qui
n'en étaient pas babineau ça c'était sur
les vaccins donc kriss kross qui ironise
je propose un élève par classe pour
prendre le minimum de risques je
comprends on nous dit nicole les
revendications sanitaire mais je ne
soutient pas la grève tout est bon
surtout pour le lycéen pour revendiquer
chris kraus comme pose lui au masque dès
6 ans babineau est d'accord avec vous
mais a three sides il ya une inquiétude
légitime de certains professeurs mais la
grève n'est pas justifiée christophe
nous dit alors christophe est d'accord
avec vous alexis bien dit alexis base et
les danses et christian léon qui ça
christophe nous dit merci qui
les profs sont tellement engagé dans
leur mission ils aimeraient bien
bénéficié d'une augmentation comme les
soignants a mon avis oui elle est prévue
elle est prévue oui mais pas à cause du
coc vide mais elle était prévue dans le
jeu alors que sa vrai sujet c'est
évidemment un sujet quand on regarde la
rémunération des professeurs c'est léger
c'est lamentable
et quand on fait des comparaisons avec
l'europe et notamment l'allemagne c'est
vrai que c'est fait enfin il ya une
dévalorisation de la profession sio
nantes qui est qui qui est pas qu'ils
aient pas qui est pas admissible
après il ya aussi la question du temps
de travail est plus tout à fait qui
épate forcément absolument le même dans
d'autres pays mais mais le d'affaires en
ce n'est quand même mais passionnant
mais c'est vrai que je dis après ce qui
coûte cher l'éducation nationale je vais
lire alors que je suis directement
concerné c'est la masse de retraités que
vous savez dans l'éducation nationale
nous sommes ceux qui vivent le doré
longtemps la masse d'administratifs non
non non non je pense pas qu'il ya une
magie administratif
écoutez moi on va dans l'université
lesquelles j'étais juge jamais été
frappée par la mode c'est autre chose
mais honnêtement bon peut-être mais ça
sera un marginal mais ce qu'il ya c'est
calais limite on peut être autant de
temps en retraite compte de temps on a
travaillé par
là je pousse un peu mais on en est
presque là or comme on a des salaires
assez faible moi j'ai toujours gagné la
moitié de ce que gagner mon époux donc
très clair et je n'ai commencé à gagner
ma vision correctement que tout à fait à
la fin j'ai fini au top du top on ne
pouvait pas faire mieux
bon mais baoulé assez exceptionnelles
etc mais néanmoins je veux je coûte
maintenant même si la libertad qu'il
n'augmente pas comme pour tous les
autres
mais j'espère vivre encore très
longtemps mais dont il repose donc je
vais je vais avoir 25 ou 30 ans de
retraite en ayant travaillé 43 ou 44 ans
donc c'est c'est un vrai problème
alors je vais dire quelque chose qui va
faire surfer sans doute mais mais mais
mes consoeurs et confrères de retraités
c'est d'une certaine façon on pourrait
voir les retraites pas tout de suite
mais baissé un peu plus dans le temps
pour pouvoir remonter les salaires c'est
à dire qu'on est un bal travailler plus
longtemps dans la vue et d'une part mais
aussi peut-être là on nous en
bénéficient de retraites de confortables
alors quand on arrive à un niveau de
salaire correct bas mais voilà ça fait
très très très aisée et peut-être qu'il
faudrait accepter d'avoir une retraite
un peu moins aisée pour pourvoir
revaloriser les salaires des jeunes
collègues
ça pourrait s'envisager mais c'est pas
demain le débat est lancé sur le site du
figaro par béatrice giblin donc vous le
dites ce que vous en pensez
babineau nous dit l'ouverture des écoles
est indispensable à la relance de
l'économie c'est ce que vous ne disiez
également en substance alexis aux vagues
fonctionnement de l'économie
pas de la relance les profs enseigne
dans des conditions de plus en plus
difficile nous dit
au nimh et christophe ne dit même pas
avec 15 élèves par classe avec certaines
populations d'élèves les profs ne
peuvent pas y arriver
bon ça c'est un autre chose c'est vrai
c'était de meetic sur le chemin
difficile notamment dans certains
quartiers oui c'est ce qu'a prouvé le
succès du hashtag pas de vagues
la question qui était posée ce était
approuvez-vous le mouvement des grèves
de grève des enseignants alors cellules
non qui l'emportent mais on est un nom à
56% et on avait on avait même commencé
l'émission à 57% une toute dernière
question on évoque la fermeture des
collèges et des écoles je sais pas vous
demander est ce que vous y croyez pas ce
qu'il ya des choses le mardi qui sont
posées on n'y croit pas et puis
finalement le jeudi allaient elles sont
elles sont mises avec tout ce qu'on est
dit avec les enjeux que ça représente je
n'y crois pas moi je crois et j'espère
je crois parce que j'espère qui fait que
que que macron laissera pas faire ça on
sent qu'il ya une tentation de redonner
un cours de vilains tours de vis
notamment sur cette question des
collèges et des lycées
je crois que là il ya quand même une
bonne nouvelle on essaie de nous les
gâcher pour pas qu'on fasse tout faut
rester raisonnable parce que sinon on va
demander qu'on ouvre les magasins et
qu'on ouvre ceci est qu'on ne recevront
donc nous voilà donc on nous dit que la
vérité c'est quand même que les efforts
sont en train de porter leurs images
donc on n'est pas obligés de relâcher on
n'est pas obligé d'en rajouter
et donc ce que ce que je crois mais on
va voir peut-être que cast exane saison
2 c'est le tour de vis il en était à 71
j'ose espérer que non que ce soit là
dessus où que ce soit sur les histoires
d'idées de d'obligations de télétravail
qui me paraissent pas pareil ne parle
pas bien j'ai tout qu'on leur courage
bon mais c'est pas la peine d'en
rajouter
et si assez vite et le plus vite
possible on pouvait ouvrir semble de
magasins dont on se demande pourquoi ils
sont fermés réouvrir les lieux de culte
réouvrira sortes de choses franchement
ça ferait mal à personne et peu montré
content on suivra ça on continuera de
suivre ça je rappelais la question
approuvez-vous le mouvement de grève des
enseignants pour réclamer un
renforcement du protocole sanitaire
contre l'accueil de 10,9 vous pouvez
continuer à voter comme vous pouvez
continuer à voter sur la question du
jour sur le site du figaro faut-il
rendre le vaccin obligatoire
alors puisqu'il ya un certain nombre de
choses qui sont fermés vos ordinateurs
ne sont pas fermés vous pouvez utiliser
son ordinateur le soin et je vous invite
ce soir là avoue rester là où vous êtes
c'est à dire sur le site du figaro
rendez-vous à 20 heures pour une soirée
spéciale consacrée au dernier numéro du
figaro hors série on va pas se contenter
de feuilleter d'ailleurs le numéro il
faut que ça vous l'achetiez sur sur
michel-ange sommités donc il est là on
va le voir on va voir le numéro on va
vous donner surtout envie de le lire en
allant à florence à rome a rencontré les
meilleurs spécialistes les meilleurs
experts avec une visite inédite de
monuments qui ne sont jamais
habituellement ouverts au public et
encore mois ouvert aux médias
sauf sauf aux caméras
bien des gens la liste du figaro hors
série est figaro live donc rendez vous à
20h et en plus en plus il y aura des
choses à gagner
à tout à l'heure sur free your life il
aurait pu s'arrêter de sculpter à 29 ans
après avoir donné au monde la pietà et
le david michel-ange allait encore
transfiguré rome de la chapelle sixtine
à la basilique saint pierre
découvrez sa vie et son oeuvre immense
dans le figaro hors-série michel-ange le
corps et l'âme le figaro hors série 164
pages en kiosque actuellement
[Musique]